[Musica]
io sono qui per dirvi che all'alba dei
miei 50 anni ho fatto pace con la mia
camicia bianca
siamo nel 2000 è l'ingresso della new
economy io mi sto laureando e c'è un
sentimento di energia e di entusiasmo
che si archi arriva addirittura
all'università
ricevo a casa delle lettere da parte di
aziende che mi chiedono di andare a fare
dei colloqui per cui ovviamente ci vado
vado a fare i miei colloqui in
un'azienda a un certo punto
miracolosamente mi assume
vado al lavoro e
c'è un problemino
io non ce l'avevo i vestiti del lavoro
di questa azienda è una multinazionale
di consulenza gigante il vestito in
queste società è fatto più o meno così
camicia bianca cravatta scura e vestito
scuro molto classico una specie di men
in black o mister henderson di matrix
prima di diventare mio
a questo punto io che ero abituato a
jeans strappati cappello al contrario
camicia lisa mi sentivo un po a disagio
e quindi me le vado a comprare sti
vestiti li compro mi avvio verso il
luogo di lavoro
tutto bene
all'inizio poi
inizio a sentire un po di fastidio
questa camicia
non mi sta tanto bene mi sento un po
stretto un po omologato anche sto
vestito faccio fatica a un certo punto
mi viene un'idea tentò una rivoluzione
copernicana
camicia grigia
cravatta grigia vestito grigio un thor
suton che poteva pure risultare
gradevole alla vista
e a questo punto fiero come il check e
vara del business me ne vado al lavoro
bello contento arrivo davanti
all'ascensore che mi portava al nono
piano del palazzo dove lavoravo
schiaccia il bottone
qualcuno mi bussa migiro il mega
direttore galattico
una specie di semidio metà uomo e metà
testa di fatturato
che mi dice ciao alessandro come stai
con quel tono simpatico poi ti danno
subito del tu guadagna 150 volte quello
che guadagno io però siamo amici da
lunga data
bene grazie tu
ti vedo un po stanco ma per che cosa
dice sì sì secondo me se un po stanchino
tu è una cosa vai a casa ti rilassi ti
cambi
e poi magari ci vediamo nel pomeriggio
non c'è problema aperto io i tuoi
colleghi il suo al nono poi sereno tutto
questo mentre dal piano terra
andavo al nono piano
io ovviamente
arrivato al nono saluto il manager
schiaccio terra e vado a rimettermi la
mia camicia bianca
vado avanti
la sensazione di costruzione continua ea
un certo punto decido senti cambio
azienda e allora vado in un'altra
multinazionale di consulenza
organizzativa è però stavolta il vestito
è diverso è è completamente diverso e
camicia bianca cravatta scura
vestito scuro
ma il problema era camicia bianca
ma non è che io magari non mi sentivo me
stesso in quell organizzazione lì
se vi dovesse chiedere chi è che si
sente se stesso al lavoro
alzate le mani
ve l'ho detto
beh però mi sembra che le percentuali ci
siano da una ricerca che abbiamo
condotto con la john hopkins university
su 13.000 persone nei cinque continenti
emerge che il 52 per cento di noi si
sente se stesse al lavoro el altra parte
no cioè voi siete voi stessi poi mi
spiace
a questo punto mi chiedo ma perché
mentiamo
perché mettiamo una maschera proprio in
quel luogo che fondamentalmente ci vedrà
lì però la maggior parte del nostro
tempo da svegli
immaginate un colloquio l'abbiamo fatto
tutti no tu vai al colloquio e vuoi
essere più energetico più produttivo più
forte talvolta anche un po più
ammiccante è però sei sempre meno padre
meno madre e un figlio
immaginando che dall'altra parte questa
cosa venga vista come buona e abbia un
esito positivo
al colloquio
in realtà oggi le organizzazioni
stanno cambiando il modo di selezionare
le persone
stanno cercando di valutare più gli
allineamenti valoriali che non solo le
skill cioè le capacità tecniche
quello che vogliono oggi come oggi è
cercare persone che stiano bene nelle
organizzazioni
certo stiamo parlando di ottime
organizzazioni che vengono valutate
anche in alcune classifiche che sono
presenti in tutto il mondo da proprio
dai loro collaboratori
e che cosa cercano oltre queste aziende
in realtà non so se avete sentito mai
parlare di great racing nation cioè
grandi dimissioni
negli ultimi due anni
abbiamo assistito un fenomeno molto
strano per cui persone soprattutto
giovani sia negli stati uniti ma anche
in europa e in nord italia
lasciavano il posto di lavoro anche
senza avere un'alternativa e quindi
questo le organizzazioni lo stanno
vivendo come un problema perché
l'investimento che fanno della assumerci
a carte quarantotto
a questo punto mi chiedo ma perché non
proviamo a essere noi stessi prendo ad
esempio mio per il prossimo colloquio il
buon vecchio neo di matrix ve lo
ricordate quando doveva saltare da un
grattacielo all'altro gli dicevano non
essere l'eletto convinciti di essere
eletto io lo prenderei un po da un altro
punto di vista proviamo a non recitare
un ruolo ma essere noi stessi
ho parlato di matrix da un paio di volte
qualcuno forse se n'è accorto
questi due sono i fratelli wachowski
sono coloro i quali hanno ideato e
diretto matrix che tutti voi conoscete
immagino per che filtra famoso e che è
famosissimo per i suoi effetti speciali
scazzotate e tante altre cose in realtà
non tutti sanno che matrix è una
straordinaria allegoria transgender è
un'allegoria che ci spiega come gli
uomini si sono liberati dalle macchine
cioè si sono liberati da un pensiero
oppressivo binario
tant'è che il buon i buoni fratelli
wachowski oggi sono
le sorelle watch chi
cioè loro nell'essere se stessi
hanno inventato una trilogia che è
diventata famosa in tutto il mondo
ci sono altri casi di questo tipo
ultimamente è stata abbastanza famosa
sui giornali a una ragazza che si chiama
jessica andy leonard e che su fa la
partner di un fondo di investimenti per
cui fondamentalmente maneggia milioni
tutto il giorno e lei si vede così su
linkedin molto classico praticamente il
mio stesso vestito versione femminile
un giorno chiede al suo manager senti io
vorrei mettere una foto un po più
personale su linkedin posso il manager
in realtà le risponde loud and proud
cioè ad alta voce e con orgoglio e gli
dice non metterla solo su linkedin ma
metti la anche nel sito aziendale la
foto è questa qui
due tatuaggi così per gradire
in quel in quel settore non è proprio di
tutti i giorni questa cosa
stefano ferri è un imprenditore
comunicativo è sposato padre di famiglia
e si piace e si veste così
ora
io credo di fare un bellissimo lavoro
in realtà come dice mia figlia a doha il
mio lavoro
e sono molto contento di farlo pensate
che io ho per mestiere chiedo alla
persone alle persone come stanno al
lavoro come stanno quel loro capi come
stanno i loro colleghi e come stanno
all'interno delle loro organizzazioni
e adesso posso dirlo
posso anche mettermi non solo la camicia
bianca mi posso mettere una felpa un
vicenza una maglietta talvolta un bel
vestito con la sua bella cravatta scura
è il suo bel vestito scuro sopra però se
mi dovessi chiedere
com'è
il mio guardaroba oggi
eccolo
50 sfumature di bianco
basco ma è quarto d'ora che mi dice che
la camicia bianca non ha sopportavi vero
però cosa succede che nel frattempo io
mi sono anche un po conosciuto e
la mattina sono un po pigro e quando mi
alzo e devo andare tra l'altro somma
schietto e mettere insieme i colori noi
facciamo una fatica bestia e la mattina
quando
e la mattina quando devo andar lì verso
l'armadio quasi ce spiccando per terra
perché tanto devo portarmi a figli
all'asilo fare 100 mila cosi metto
dentro una mano tiro fuori una camicia e
me la metto anche se bianca
quello che abbiamo visto oggi è un
viaggio straordinario che hanno fatto
questi ragazzi forse molto molto più
lungo e difficile del nostro ma se avete
voglia se ve la sentite vostra e se ve
lo sentite dentro e buona camicia bianca
a tutti
[Applauso]
[Musica]
sì